was that ever like a switch where you
noticed oh being a nerd's actually cool
now
absolutely but i think
okay so i'm like pretty like headstrong
and pretty loud and obnoxious than i
always was
right i was also like obsessed with
x-files like in like a
dangerous manner right what about
like it's just so nerdy and it's like
kind of older and nerdy and like nobody
gives a [ __ ] and i'd literally
like go around singing like weird songs
i made up about mulder and scully and
how they should be together
and stuff and like i would um this is
the same people who like this eventually
turned into supernatural fans
oh my god yes but um
definitely and like i don't know like i
think i just didn't really
care and nobody really made fun of me
for it
because yeah i don't know i guess
there's like no reason to it's like oh
like look at that little
asian girl being obsessed with this like
weird alien show
or whatever and um i was in ap
studio art and i would like i would
literally draw
scully and boulder and once i drew them
[ __ ] and yeah
i just like i i did it i was like x
false doujin
yeah i like rule 34 like mulder and
scully
and i tried to submit it for one of my
like studio profiles
and they it got rejected so fast and so
hard and so
yeah well i know right it was so
beautiful was it embrace it
yeah romantic embraceable it was
romantic it wasn't like
hot and raunchy it was romantic and
beautiful and then
they went [ __ ] they were making love
thank you very much
it belongs it deserves to be on a roof
of a church
truly it's it's very it was very
acceptable
[Laughter]
tasteful is the word i don't know if it
was tasteful you could see
like some nipple but like but um i
i didn't understand why they would like
reject it so quickly so i would modify
and i'd like turn it into mixed media
and i'd put like oil paintings on it and
then i'd like put some acrylic on it so
it would like cover you already
committed to this this drawing huh
it's like be submitted so you know i'd
like try to
fix it but it was still rejected because
they knew what the original one was
but anyway my whole point was like i
really wore it on my sleeve without
really giving a [ __ ] so there was no
making fun of me like what are you gonna
make fun of me for liking this show
like [ __ ] so
i don't know i feel a lot of kids though
like especially back then we're not as
strong as
you were yeah right it was a very
empowering moment i realized wait i can
just like
not care and then people won't it's like
whoa you can do that yeah
well and then people will like not make
fun of me because they realize
i don't care i'm sure they made fun of
me in secret
like it doesn't matter right yeah
for sure just don't care it's uh such a
cheap code to life right
yeah seriously truly yeah